en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre las
diferentes maneras de estructurar una
economía en particular determinar quién
es dueño de qué y cómo en una economía
se decide qué producir y quien recibirá
el resultado de dicha producción por un
lado tenemos las economías de estado un
buen ejemplo de estas son los países
comunistas especialmente durante el
siglo 20 y el mejor ejemplo de ellos fue
la unión soviética en una economía de
estado la producción estará a cargo del
gobierno el cual es dueño de los
factores de producción y en casos
extremos no existe la propiedad privada
en una economía de estado es frecuente
que el gobierno sea dueño de las
fábricas las granjas y demás factores de
producción aquí dibujamos una fábrica el
gobierno le dice a esta fábrica que este
año tiene que producir exactamente
10.000 automóviles ni uno más ni uno
menos y las personas de esta fábrica le
dicen ok tú eres el que manda tú eres el
gobierno vamos a producir exactamente 10
mil autos esta fábrica no tiene más
opción que producir la cantidad exacta
de automóviles que le pide el gobierno
similar el gobierno le puede decir a una
granja que dibujamos más o menos así que
tiene que producir 10 millones de
manzanas ni siquiera sé si es un número
razonable de manzanas pero necesita 10
millones de manzanas y los granjeros
quienes trabajan para el gobierno ya que
el gobierno es el dueño de esa granja
tienen que producir esas manzanas en la
economía de estado también se controla
quiénes son los que van a recibir estos
automóviles y estas manzanas y en un
caso extremo de economía de estado es el
gobierno quién los asigna directamente
el gobierno decide si esta persona
recibe un auto esta otra recibe un auto
y esta otra también recibe un auto esta
asignación no estará basada en quienes
quieren pagar por ese auto o en quien
puede pagar más por ese auto con las
manzanas ocurre algo similar todas serán
asignadas por el gobierno por lo que
habrá que hacer una gran planeación por
parte del gobierno para decidir cuándo
debemos producir de una cosa en
comparación con otras coches o manzanas
y cómo decidir quién es recibida por
otra parte del otro lado del espectro
tenemos lo que se conoce como
unidad de mercado y la mayoría de las
economías en el mundo son más similares
a la economía de mercado que a la
economía de estado en la economía de
mercado a diferencia del estado que
determina y asigna que producir el
mercado o la economía de mercado está
marcada por la competencia en lugar de
que el gobierno sea el dueño de los
factores de producción y decida qué
produce quién y cuándo y asignar quién
recibe qué cosa en una economía de
mercado por ejemplo tenemos una empresa
que es en su mayor parte independiente
del gobierno aunque existen ciertos
tipos de empresas que tienen una mayor
influencia del gobierno por ejemplo la
milicia en esta empresa se preguntan
cuáles son las necesidades del mercado
podrían decir que el mercado requiere
5000 automóviles que lucen así pero
también requiere de 2.000 camiones cómo
saben esto con base en la información
que tuvieron el año anterior por ejemplo
que también se vendieron los camiones y
los autos o qué es lo que vendieron sus
competidores en una economía de mercado
es muy común tener más competencia en la
economía de estado es posible tener una
fábrica enorme qué es
del gobierno o de unos pocos mientras
que en la economía de mercado podemos
tener varias empresas más pequeñas que
compiten entre sí una puede decidir
hacer un auto similar al de su
competencia pero en otro color por
ejemplo un coche amarillo nuevamente en
una economía de mercado tenemos esta
noción de competencia entre las personas
que producen cosas para este mercado así
como su mejor juicio para ver las
necesidades de dicho mercado del mismo
modo tenemos aquí una granja en donde se
han producido muchas manzanas pero
pareciera que dichas manzanas no tienen
mucha demanda ya que parece que los
duraznos están de moda este año y en
este caso la forma en la que se asignan
los productos no está dictada por el
gobierno sino que es determinada por el
mercado
digamos que aquí estoy yo que aquí estás
tú y aquí alguien más quizás yo no estoy
interesada en comprar el camión pero sí
necesito un auto nuevo para transportar
a mi familia y digamos que tú también
necesitas un auto pero es el mercado el
que indica quién lo va a tener la
fábrica asigna un precio a este auto
digamos que es de 10 mil pesos quizá
estoy dispuesta a pagarlo o quizá no me
puede parecer caro pagar 10 mil pesos
por este auto pero veo que este otro
auto cuesta 9 mil pesos así que voy a
comprar este otro incluso los precios no
necesariamente están fijos si no se
venden suficientes autos de este tipo
pueden bajar el precio de 10 mil pesos a
9 mil para competir con este auto
amarillo de forma similar si muchas
personas quieren comprar este camión
puede aumentar el precio de este camión
o producir más de este si existe una
gran competencia y una empresa no logra
competir en algunas de estas situaciones
es posible que tenga que salir del
negocio por lo que hay una fuerte
motivación para cumplir con las
necesidades del mercado y los precios se
ajustan de acuerdo a esto entonces
cuáles son los aspectos positivos y
negativos que se asocian generalmente a
estas economías uno de los beneficios
asociados a la economía de estado es una
noción de equidad o alguna idea de
igualdad y por otra parte en la economía
de mercado una consecuencia de éste
mismo en donde muchas personas compiten
entre sí algunas personas pueden
trabajar más que otras algunas pueden
innovar más o algunas personas pueden
tener buena o mala suerte naturalmente
tendremos cierto nivel de desigualdad
algunas de las ideas originales detrás
de la economía de estado como el
comunismo es que la desigualdad no es
buena por lo que queremos asegurarnos de
que todos reciban exactamente lo mismo
que tengan exactamente el mismo auto y
que reciban exactamente la misma
cantidad de manzanas no queremos que
todas estas empresas compitan entre sí
queremos una gran empresa eficiente que
se haga cargo de fabricar los autos
resulta que en la realidad esta idea es
muy utópica aún en la época dorada de
estas economías de estado había personas
con un mayor acceso a estas cosas
quienes eran más cercanos a los
gobernantes tenían acceso a mejores
autos a mejores departamentos y a más
recursos en comparación con otras
personas por otra parte en una economía
de mercado aún cuando existe cierta
desigualdad y la razón por la cual la
mayoría de las economías
incluyendo las que son nominalmente
comunistas como la de china han hecho la
transición a la economía de mercado es
debido a que este tipo de economías se
asocian a cosas como la innovación e
incentivos para que la gente trabaje o
genera cosas nuevas
pensemos en la siguiente situación en
una economía de estado digamos que eres
administrador de esta fábrica y el
gobierno te pide que produzcas 10.000
autos quizás tengas una idea para hacer
este auto más eficiente pero nadie te va
a recompensar por esto no te van a pagar
más para que puedas comprar más cosas
por lo que es probable que no estés tan
motivado para hacer esto en cambio en la
economía de mercado tienes mucha
competencia esta empresa comienza a
vender más todas las personas en esta
otra empresa pensarán en cómo innovar y
trabajarán más duro para poder tener una
mayor participación en el mercado algo
similar ocurre a nivel individual quizá
alguien solo tenga lo suficiente como
para comprar el auto amarillo pero
realmente quiera el auto azul por lo que
trabajará más duro o tratará de innovar
o abrirá un negocio para poder ganar más
y poder
el auto azul así que la mayoría de las
economías en el mundo son más parecidas
a la economía de mercado porque aunque
existe algo de desigualdad hay más
productividad más innovación más bienes
y servicios disponibles para las
personas pero aunque la mayoría de las
economías en el mundo son parecidas a la
economía de mercado no existe la
economía de mercado perfecta pues en
muchas áreas de la industria el gobierno
se encuentra muy involucrado en muchas
economías el gobierno puede encargarse
de la salud pública y en la gran mayoría
de las economías el gobierno tiene
tremenda influencia en la industria
militar por ejemplo en los eeuu que es
una economía fuertemente capitalista el
gobierno ofrece seguridad social cuando
la desigualdad se vuelve extrema cuando
alguien no puede comprar alimentos por
su cuenta puede recibir bonos de
alimento o alguien que no tiene acceso a
servicios de salud por la situación de
pobreza puede tener acceso a los
servicios sociales de salud existe un
espectro entre la economía de estado y
la economía de mercado la mayor
de las economías se encuentran en este
espectro por lo que se denominan
economías mixtas por ejemplo como
mencioné antes los eeuu de américa es un
país fuertemente capitalista con
economía de mercado pero aún tiene
cuestiones que son de dominio público
el gobierno controla ciertos aspectos de
la economía
representando gran influencia en las
decisiones económicas en resumen en una
economía de estado pura el gobierno
controla todo el mercado y en una
economía de mercado el gobierno controla
una parte muy pequeña de la economía
pero en la mayor parte del mundo las
economías se encuentran en lo que
llamamos economía mixta y con esto
terminamos